this is such an inspiring story because
it shows how mathematicians can save
lives we're talking about one of the
most famous cipher machines of all time
is a code machine called the Enigma
machine used by Nazi Germany in World
War two to send secret coded messages
and we've got one over here this is not
a copy this is not a replica this is an
original Enigma machine actually used in
World War two this was made in 1936 it's
an Army Enigma machine let's see how it
works so this belongs to a man called
Simon Singh he's an author he writes
popular science books and he lends it to
the University of Cambridge where I work
this was found in a French field I was
told by an American cryptographer after
the war and he took it home so I guess
he took it home as this souvenir yonk
that's mine the guy found it died about
12 years ago and when he died that's
when Simon Singh bought to the machine
we're gonna send a message now we were
talking about what to send before so he
send them a file let's turn this into
Enigma code so I'm going to type in end
to begin with and if you can see there
the letter Y lights up so n becomes Y
your code lights up let's write that
down let's do the next letter U u
becomes T let's do em and I've got H
this time B and E is W notice here we
had Y turn up twice and they turned up
for two different letters so n became Y
then later on he became Y that's unusual
the other unusual thing you may notice
is that the two E's in number file have
turned into two different letters so
here he became Y but the second II
became W now this is why the Germans
thought they had an unbreakable code
old-fashioned codes in the past pen and
paper codes that they used to use if you
had the same letter it would become the
same letter in
code enigma is different probably each
time you did it you would get a
completely different code now if we can
break this code and by we I mean the
Polish the British and the Americans if
we can break this code in World War two
we'll be able to read those Germans
secret messages which is what we did so
let me show you how this machine works
let me open up the machine so we have
three things here at the top these
things are called rotors and inside
those rotors try and imagine lots of
wiring and it's all criss-crossed wiring
as well now if I press a letter have a
look what happens the rotors move when
this rotor does a full turn it will kick
the next rotor one place and then the
right-hand rotor keeps going eventually
the middle rotor does a full turn and it
will kick the left-hand rotor one place
so a fast rotor a middle rotor and a
slow rotor imagine it like it's hands on
a clock like you've got a minute hand in
an hour hand in a second hand that's the
idea brilliant machine though this is
all it is really it's just a circuit
here is a battery you can see that's a
modern battery in there we've converted
this and this battery is connected to a
bulb and it lights up it's the most
simple thing you can make a battery in a
bulb with the bulb lights up and that's
all it is the clever bit is the wires of
the circuit are inside the rotors so
when the wires turn the battery will
connect to a different bulb let's try
and see that happen so I'm going to turn
the wires and the battery connects to
this book do it again I'm going to turn
this book changes do it again turn the
wires and the battery connects to this
book and that's why it changes each time
because it has moving parts inside but
otherwise it's just a simple circuit I
think we need to know how to decode this
would be no good if we can't decode
iMessage so let's do that right first of
all we're going to take our code here we
need to know what the setting was now if
you notice in the little windows we have
three numbers it's like a combination
lock like a bike lock
now I took a note of what those three
numbers were those three numbers when we
started writing numberphile we're 13 9
and 21 so the idea is you would type in
your message and you would get a code
the machine itself doesn't transmit so
you would have to write that code on a
piece of paper so that piece of paper
would be given to the radio operator who
would then transmit the message by radio
by Morse code that would travel miles
away so now imagine a second German
officer maybe on a ship somewhere in the
ocean
now he's tuning into that radio signal
he can hear the code it's coming in and
he writes it down now this second
officer will have a Enigma machine as
well and here's an Enigma machine is
exactly the same as the first one so
there's something I have to do I now
need to set these rotors to the correct
position so we've got this code over
here why th my and whatever let's type
that into the machine this time and see
what happens okay so we start with y Y
becomes n t becomes u H becomes M M in
the code is a B Y I F and W finally is e
so each rotor has 26 starting places in
fact these rotors come out and swap over
in fact again they had five rotors to
pick from he had a box of five rotors
you've picked three from a box of five
and already we've got thousands of
settings and each one will produce a
different code so we're going to work
out those combinations so the first
thing I said was we pick three rotors
for a box of five in the first slot you
would have five rotors to pick from once
you've picked that in the second place
you would have four rotors to pick from
and in the final place the third place
you were three rotors left and you
multiply those numbers together so it's
five times four times three so there
sixty ways that you can put in three
rotors from a choice of five we have 26
starting positions for each rotor so we
have 26 choices for the first one 26
choices for the second one and 26
choices for the third one and if you do
that you get 26 cubed which is 17,576 it
gets worse because the military the Army
Air Force Navy had something extra the
commercial machines if you are a bank or
a business you could buy an enigma
machine to use yourself to send your own
sequence that the military had an extra
bit they had this thing at the front of
the machine now this is called a plug
board and what it is it's like an
old-fashioned telephone switchboard like
an old patch board we have 10 of these
wires and each of these wires connect to
letters into a pair so in this case you
might see the letter Q is going to
connect with the letter e now you make
10 of those pairs to letters and a pair
will swap over so if Q is connected to e
then Q and E would swap over
that's an extra level of scrambling only
available to the military now this had
the most number of combinations now this
calculation is going to be the hardest
calculation but we can do it so there
are 26 letters in the alphabet
how many ways to arrange 26 letters
where it's 26 times 25 times 24 all the
way down to one that's 26 factorial but
we don't want every combination of 26
letters we only want to make 10 pairs so
that means there are six letters left
over which we don't care about because
we don't care about them that means we
are allowed to divide and we're going to
divide by six factorial now there are
ten pairs we don't care what order those
ten pairs are in because we don't care
about it we can divide by 10 factorial
and the last thing to divide by two
letters in a pair well if I swap them
over that would still be the same pair
if I had a and B
that's the same as bein a that's still
the same pair so I can divide by two and
I do that for each pair there's ten
pairs so I'm going to divide by two ten
times it is 2 to the power 10 and that
is how many ways that you can connect 20
letters into 10 pairs on the front of
the machine how big is that number shall
we do that 150 trillion 738 billion 274
million nine hundred and thirty seven
thousand two hundred and fifty so the
total 158 quintillion 962 quadrillion
555 trillion 217 billion eight hundred
and twenty six million 360,000 flat that
is the total number of ways that you can
set the Enigma machine this would be an
army Enigma machine around about 1939
you were telling me that the Germans
would send each other messages like oh
you know syn send the u-boat to this
position or whatever but how were they
telling each other their plug settings
and they're starting rotor numbers so
this is very important so these two
people who are miles apart need to have
the same setting though the setting was
written down for you on a piece of paper
well they would have is a sheet of paper
like that and it would be a big sheet of
paper for each day of the month so it
was a monthly sheet for each day of the
month II told you how to set the machine
for that day but he didn't have this
sheet of paper you wouldn't know what
the setting was that you had to use for
that day a nice little story the Navy
would write these code books in soluble
ink so if you get sunk you get caught
and you throw the codebook into water
that's how you keep the secret it sounds
to me that all you need is an Enigma
machine
and a copy of that book and you know
everything they're saying you would do
so if you had the machine and you had
that code sheet you would be able to
decode all the messages fantastic great
but we had we had the machine and once
we've had the machine we can pull it
apart and find out how it works great
but it was getting those code sheets
that was difficult
they were monthly they would change
every month if you did capture them
which we did occasionally you could use
it until it runs out but without a code
sheet you would have to break the code
and you would have to do that with
mathematics what was the key what what
was wrong with enigma what was its
weakness let's have a look at what the
flaw is in the Enigma machine so the
Germans thought it was unbreakable but
there is a flaw if I press a letter K